cobra kai season 3 episode 6 king
cobra guys excited to swing into this
the season just keeps getting better and
better if you haven't done so already
subscribe click that notification bell
if you enjoy our reaction
hit that like button if you just like
the fact that we're doing this hit the
like button i don't need to go over all
the details again
reaction highlights only for youtube
thank you to everyone who's been joining
our patreon page already this month
alone
following through action watchalongs for
this or all over at our patreon page
where we cover a whole bunch of shows
anywho let's get down to business
and i have to throw this insert in here
right now that uh wasn't part of the
original plan because
we got someone who we actually met
through our patreon our friend bradley
bledsoe
who you can follow on twitter sketchy
studio zero just to help us keep up with
being able to get all these reactions up
daily had to hire someone bradley
bledsoe thank you for editing
the reaction highlights for us dude
you've been putting in a lot of hard
work give him a follow on his own
channel where he has his own sketches
and stuff i mean give him a follow on
social media
thank you again for last minute being
able to help us edit because
it's been quite a lot anywho let's get
to that reaction
vietnam this must be miguel's backstory
yeah i finally get to see why he's so
brooding
it's all that perfume it's the smell of
america hey tell her to send one for me
what's the smell of america
grace command tent some captain's in
there asking for you
is it a dojo master is it that guy from
karate kid three or something good
that's a thick-ass cigar seriously it's
the thickest cigar i've ever seen
guerrilla tactics demolitions hand-hand
combat
what kind of hand the hell are we
talking about sir oh future enemy you
gotta learn how to fight like your enemy
we need brutality guys crease just like
traumatized is that this whole thing
probably
just like recreating jesus i'm still
glad we went to high school in the 80s
no question we had the best music
hell yeah
[Laughter]
i remember we used to see each other
every day now i don't even know the
first thing about you
don't like all the photos don't leave
too many comments
what are you up to these days assaulted
several miners
just repeat the rapture from that time
we tried to apply for the job
hey wait till i tell you what happened
over there
i met up with my ex let's start
with that guy who wanted to kill me
considering there's a cape fear level
karate psycho terrorizing
it sounds crazy when you say it out loud
it's a great description though
yeah but they got what they deserve for
what they did to mcgill you still
haven't seen him yet have you
i don't want to talk about it i'm really
disturbed by that
good deflection hawk oh my god
it got
oh i hope that guy puts him in his place
that's
probably what it'll take are you writing
a novel
jesus christ johnny oh johnny facebook
no you're writing a novel tldr johnny
you cannot send her that message why not
because it's like 80 pages
[Laughter]
sending her this would be like if you
like if you liked all of her photos
she put a smiley face in the message
she's even got little red cheeks
does that mean she's getting hot she's
feeling hot
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] this kid with the lid
yeah i thought it moved did they not go
to the same school anymore
he is not sorry just like hawk has a
pretty big reputation
ready whoa
they're gonna start mixing their martial
arts
finishing jesus christ
what do you mean by finish him no
hesitation
no second thoughts and no mercy
i said no mercy i know what that
is
jesus oh no where did this decree
understood oh should break up with him
or is it his mom no his mom's reading
that she's already dead that's right
oh no or did she die too oh hell yeah
yeah leave one of those lead with those
do you have anywhere you're wearing a
shirt maybe there you go how's that
i love johnny he's seriously the best
you think the aquarium will let me get
in there with the dolphins
i don't know
[Music]
yeah a restraining order that's right ah
nah he can get around a restraining
order emergency protective order has
already been filed
oh he filed it against her i feel like
this story is missing a lot of context
[Music]
you smacked him i mean to be here sign
here to acknowledge you've been served
these papers
oh my god all right who's going down
next
let's go he's mine oh
[ __ ] see if i can fix that lippy ears
oh no no
ah
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
wow
[Laughter]
is he changing his clothes how did you
bring looks like
oh what the hell was this [ __ ] it's so
dry delicious
basically you have some fresh avocados
some chopped up cucumbers
all the time is doing karate
miguel i know you're helping your mom
but
when you need help oh
i still don't like her how about you do
a deal
with me um mm-hmm sleep with him i want
you to
evict a tenant in your receita strip
mall is this about uh snake karate
why would i evict him no i want uh
triple oh my god
yeah deal
oh because chris gonna harm this guy or
chris could just continue training
or he's gonna harm that guy uh
that's my guess yeah ponytail is in
position
all right we're live
no
look at him crease
oh jesus this is the worst time to evict
him
after having this flashback you have to
leave today
eric
oh no i got to get their ass is whooped
ugh you're the one giving up i don't
know what the heck quiet
you helped a bunch of people and then
walked away like a [ __ ] that's who you
are if you can't see them
i'm doing it
oh what a good scene sensei awesome
join my dojo
too oh she just said what she's been
outside
dealership's back on its feet creases
out of our lives oh no chris is going to
come right back in the zoo
isn't he doing this he's going to like
throw a brick through the window
this is like every anime where they talk
about how they're going to win
i can't believe it's over here we go
that deal is off what we had an
agreement
[Music]
oh jesus
oh dude oh too far
this is where we draw the line this
show's so good
so good it's so good such a good show
such a good show it's crazy how much
they're like humanizing crease
yeah and everyone he's rubbed off on i
mean with crease though like
bringing all these flashbacks into the
fold and really getting a sense for the
traumatizing experiences he had a you
know
already with his loss of his mom you
already get a sense of a real disturbing
childhood he had as well
just based off of like interactions he
had with the people who were bullying
him at the restaurant
going to these vietnam war flashbacks
it's pretty brutal for this show
i mean the show goes brutal but it's
like fight scenes and stuff
but a lot of times they don't they might
not show you certain parts
but i was like this feels like a
different show you feel like you're
plucked into like some type of war
series at this point you know
and it does make all of this
feel that much more believable
absolutely
because before i was just kind of
rolling with it like this is fun this is
a little ridiculous
you know like man they take cobra kai
and karate
way too seriously but then when you get
the the the idea that kris is just a
a super traumatized guy that trauma
can be felt and then also influenced
upon others
and you see that happen with johnny you
see it happening with these other
students where
despite whatever feelings that you might
get of hints like with tori and hawk and
the looks they
give that something's wrong you know
like traumatized they still go through
with that anyway this show is dealing
with these
elements especially this season in
particular from what we've gotten with
sam and what she's dealing with
we've gotten that plenty with johnny of
course over the course of this whole
series but damn like everyone's dealing
with trauma
and with crease especially suddenly all
the stuff that was kind of silly about
it you're like no this makes a lot of
sense when this guy
does this now especially when you see
the full-on outcome with the bomb and
everything and
one moment of hesitation and they they
set it up like there's a piece of
dialogue early on that
sets it up like oh he can't have this
kind of emotional distraction you know
out there in the field it's the kind of
thing that can get a person killed
and it's one of those things where i
wasn't thinking about like i was
definitely gonna come back
and it's again an ear mark of like the
sensibility of this series like they
really made yeah an
earnest piece out of all those
flashbacks to where yeah it didn't feel
out of place somewhere no no no yeah
very well removed
from a lot of the places and context
we're familiar with so far
yeah it's really impressive and you see
he's so scary he's like
he's so scary you just have no idea what
reactive mode he's gonna go to next
like oh he's like he's gonna show up the
guy who owns the building he's gonna
show up
and his crew's gonna kill him he's gonna
burst through the russo's
auto group store is he gonna do that and
then oh man the snake one just
damn just when they got their reputation
back
on track cobra
oh damn that was that was a good reveal
yeah i'm really enjoying everything that
this show's doing
from beginning from beginning to end the
relationship with amanda and danny i
feel like
amanda should have really mentioned the
slap moment yeah that one especially
well like i don't know for all the
things that have happened physically
between characters on this show that's
about
you know the least outlandish thing to
have happened just smacked him across
the face you know
it makes sense for crease to pull that
call
oh yeah what a [ __ ] move oh great
because that's exactly what his students
do it at the school is they're just like
oh no man you know we're totally in line
with the status quo
it's them who's out of line and if you
use people's it's like using weight
against someone in a fight you use their
own anger and ire against them and i
feel like they're great at
building tension out of that too when it
comes to the sides of like
hawk or tori that do seem a little more
human and a little more aware
of their moral or lack of
moral guidance you know and yeah it's
great because on the flip side you see
how crease
empowers them and it makes for a really
compelling like
where's everybody gonna end up because i
want them to be salvaged but i
have a feeling some of them can't be
it's funny to me how
none of the students were because
especially when they bring in the cops
section to this
like what about all the people who leave
cobra guy yeah they're witness to things
that just
are not like as much more believable as
exploring the backstory increase and all
that has made
all this obsession and passion and the
amount of trauma that gets
you know displaced over into karate
like i i get that just like man
you don't conduct a karate school like
that it's like underground fighting
meets karate
yeah his operation must send multiple
people to hospitals and rack up a lot of
medical
bills i think it's ridiculous yeah and i
can't believe that not
one parent has has done anything
about this or yeah like there would have
to be someone
like if you said a bunch of kids are
getting their noses and arms and stuff
broken or walking out bloodied from this
place
yeah i feel like someone's gonna go
investigate this yeah
um but yeah at the same time it doesn't
really bother me
it's just funny it's just fun to me yeah
it works with the [ __ ] that's where
you're working for the show which is
funny
and i mean i guess you could argue that
you know it's what crease attracts is
people who
care or like to maintain that level of
bloodlust and so who
maybe aren't going to go and tattle
anyway
but when uh when hawk lets out all that
aggression and trauma it's that's i mean
dealing with trauma like he's
they even show with hawk he's
traumatized from the events of being
bullied
he even has a little bit of a panic mode
and then taking the cobra kai approach
which is attack it with the utmost
aggression
that's how you overcome your pain and
just attack it with violence
that was a brutal scene there weren't a
full fight club in that moment full of
edward norton jared leto it's more
painful to watch
hawk unload his fists than it is to see
the guy being pummeled in because your
imagination kind of fills in the gap of
how
brutal it is you know after a while
you're like please don't cut back to him
please
yeah and that scene was perfect too
because
yeah i love the way that they're playing
with and like i was reminded of sam
in the last episode because i was like
oh is this gonna be a turn or is this
moment of trauma going to get the better
of her and it does whereas this one i
was like oh okay
we're setting up for maybe hawk is about
to be dethroned but
no bringing those bullies back into the
fold
does remind you of why hawk has gone to
this level of extremity yeah with
this persona he's adopted and his
commitment to this level of violent
level cobra kai
that's not me of how he how he was
treated for so long so i'm like
yeah i got to keep that in mind like
he's done a full slingshot effect
because
he's had years of that kind of crap to
put up with so it makes sense
but johnny miguel oh going back to them
being the heart of this series this is
that was even though he's
one of the last things we're talking
about here's my favorite part of this
whole episode
it's so funny it's so funny and they
have such good
unexpected scene work i like i love that
last scene when he's trying to help him
walk
miguel's calling him out on his [ __ ]
and
how he's been running away and he's
saying like you're supposed to be the
sensei and all that and
then you see the action of like really
help miguel walk just there understand
he's learning how to be a real sensei a
real mentor
you know in his own fashion by not he's
not trying to duplicate
or mirror the cobra highways anymore
he's finding his own style he's still
got his johnny lawrence edge
his 80s personality to it all
but he's doing it his own way and he's i
love that he's becoming an actual sensei
oh yeah
especially like on this one-on-one he is
the miyagi
too daniel russo with their relationship
but in their own very own fashion
yeah and to build him back up in that
way i think it makes a lot of spiritual
sense to
yeah bring it back to a one-on-one
scenario with this one student and you
remove
karate so that you just have these
themes of he's guiding him and
encouraging and helping
build him up and sort of revealing what
miguel maybe doesn't believe he has
within him already
at least you know given the physical
limitations and yeah like
every scene and again even the little
ones even like the goofy little moments
like their chemistry is just like
it was always i've always loved it but
it's just like singing more than
ever to me as of these past couple
episodes
it wasn't really there in season two it
wasn't it wasn't as prevalent it rogue
mcgill
and then here it's like this is all they
have is each other at this point
and it's back to that you know and they
have the history to bring along with it
as opposed to getting to know one
another
they already love each other yeah yeah
and because of that they can speak on
these levels
yeah yeah so that's why i think it's
it's so much stronger so
they really are the heart of this you
don't cut to robbie at all in this
episode
which kind of surprised me the tory
stuff
i don't know i'm so back and forth at
tori i'm not even that back and forth
i i've have a really hard time i feel
like the show will tell me to be like
sympathetic towards her dying mom like
we got to be dying mom
she works a lot to take care of her mom
okay
i feel like we have it's like a
character note they've included in the
script of her character that
i'm like but whenever i'm with her i
just don't like her i i don't like and i
feel like
the show leans way more into that as
opposed to trying to really flush her
out
but then again my recollection of my
experiences whether a character in
season two
i remember facts and beats like they
used to date
tori was new girl who showed up to cope
like i remember these little things
but my emotional experience with her is
not as
strong in memory at the moment i feel
like they could do a little more
to yeah make her character feel a bit
more lived in or maybe give her some
like we've spent maybe one episode that
had a focal tory
plotline in it this season and i
something about it does feel a little
more mathematical like oh here is her
trauma in fitting with kind of breaking
down what
motivates all these kids to you know
join up with karate and face these types
of issues but
yeah i feel like we hinted the most at
it in that scene with miguel
some kind of vulnerability from her and
i feel like it's that temperance that
i'm
missing it's like with hawk even though
i sometimes complain that he's like evil
we've at least been there with him as of
season one we
saw him where he came from and we've
seen him in more vulnerable moments
whereas like
maybe if the mom was a character yeah
maybe if we got to spend a little time
with her out of her element or out of
the place where she's putting up that
wall in that guard because she is one of
the most guarded characters it seems
like
because you know like she seems to go
there's something that's kind of human
about it
you know to go from break dimitri's arm
like shouting finish it
and then to show up the next day and be
like i didn't think you'd actually do it
like to be so caught up
in the aggression of the moment yeah and
then when you're
through when your emotions are not that
high suddenly that wall is a little bit
more vulnerable
and then you're feeling all those
feelings underneath the anger so there's
something that is pretty human about
that to me because sometimes i find
myself judging her but then in my mind
we'll go well that's kind of a human
thing though
like oh i felt i feel guilty about these
things or seeming disturbed by
like surprised by all that [ __ ] that a
[ __ ] hawk did but i'm like but you're
the one taking him on but that's also
human to be in the moment and do that
and even with miguel like oh i feel
guilty you you do a lot of
you still do horrible things you know
yeah
so but that's what i mean she when she's
caught up in the moment of the anger and
the violence stuff
it could seem like she's being
hypocritical but there's something
that's three-dimensional about it on
another spectrum i don't know if i'm
reading more into it to give the show
more credit or
if that's an actual thing that the
show's doing i feel like she
definitely fits thematically and she
definitely helps to kind of exemplify
because like within the cobra kai and
especially in that laser tag
scene you kind of see the latent like
pure
pressure thing that could potentially
choke out these little notes of
is this going too far well i guess if
nobody else thinks so i can't you know
look weak
by you know objecting so and i feel like
you know i'll pick those nuances
especially up out of her sometimes
but yeah i feel like it's just maybe we
could use a few more tenders for her
i love i love johnny figuring out social
media too
him talking with ali and i love how
they've been building up the return of
ali
we don't really know all the details too
even in that message like
there's so much still to uncover when
will she return
physically in the show she clearly took
photos for the show
she has to appear either as a cameo or a
guest star in one of these episodes but
probably more of a prevailing character
in
season four who knows but i love the way
they're building it but more importantly
more than just a nostalgia factor of
bringing elizabeth shoe back
alley they're using it to build up the
johnny character
you know still chasing another thing
from his past dealing with that whole
conversation of
putting up this facade lying to your ex
to present yourself as something you're
not that's what that's why i think it's
so cool what they're doing with her
because it could have just been she's
back
yay cool she's in the show but they're
they're doing it in a much smarter way
to enhance it make it feel
like a real essential part to the growth
of johnny
yeah which i think is fascinating i'm
really impressed with this show i like
how
like like if you guys start watching
reactions from episode one
we've gone from so much more jokes to
taking this
like progressively more serious history
they're
really good at riding that light really
good at riding that drama
i just became very self-aware of our
experience of just like so many jokes
too less jokes as time goes on
[ __ ] just keeps getting more and more
real
i mean our energy and mood is always a
reflection of whatever we're reacting to
so yeah that makes sense all right guys
well cobra kai i don't know leave it or
the hell you want to leave down in the
comments she has birds in the show
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button check out our
patreon page if you want thank you to
bradley for editing this video
make sure to go check out his channel i
said
am bedtime later than that probably all
right sketchy studios
check out his channel man last but not
least
of course shout out bradley thanks for
editing the video buddy
every time we hire you for a little edit
and we should
go let's take his patreon pledge and put
it back
into bradley's pocket right right this
is just a bonus for you just a bonus
we're both winning we're both saving
ourselves here
thank you bro how have you enjoyed cobra
kai catching up for it just to be able
to edit
i appreciate the work you're putting in
man you're kicking so much ass
lately you've been working your butt off
i hope 2021 is a pleasure for you man
pleasure yourself in 2021 i really have
enjoyed getting to know you
i really have enjoyed it we've been
talking like every other day because we
have to
you know to coordinate everything i
don't want to
but now that we're working together
we're like a
real friend now i actually care about
what happens in your life and your
why i get back to you guys more than my
fiance
it's causing problems around here you're
ruining the owners
falling on me and i'm not equipped for
that
john's are really bad at it i'm a bad
lover
anyway bradley thank you for being here
coach
[Music]